[Music]
all right it's only 13 months into this
presidency President Trump is gearing up
to run for re-election today in fact it
was announced that Brad parse Cal will
in fact serve as his campaign manager
for the Trump twenty20 re-election
joining us now with more as president
Trump's daughter-in-law who will serve
as a senior advisor to Donald J Trump
for president on the reelection
committee Laura Trump is with us good to
see again how are you how's the baby
he's so good yeah I saw the picture when
he was actually sitting in the
presidency yeah very nice and then with
the hair I know that's his signature do
now the hair seems straight up and you
should let out on social media and
everything or no some pictures are very
cute thank you
the interesting thing is you have
actually been doing this for a while
this really isn't news to me well thank
you I well first of all I was so honored
to play a role in the 2016 campaign I
was out on the road all the time
Erick was out on the road Don we all
were doing our part and then come
January last year I was honored again to
be part of the campaign and everyday
work alongside the great people that we
have there and we were thrilled today to
announce Brad parse Cal as the campaign
manager for 12 many years he's gonna be
awesome he's gonna do such a great job
he was such a huge part of why the
president is in office today other than
the fact that he was such a great
candidate and the country loved him the
digital campaign the digital portion of
the campaign was so important and Brad
was 100% behind that and she's gonna do
a great job every night on this show I
talked about the media in this country
they've reported for well over a year
Trump Russia collusion there's smoke
that they tell us but there's no fire
there's nothing there they have nothing
now but we have found evidence that
Hillary Clinton bought and paid for an
unverified Russian Russian government
dossier that then was used for a FISA
abuse and they didn't tell the FISA
judge that she bought and paid for it
and it was unverified if you tried to
write it into a movie script Sean people
wouldn't even believe it it's the world
that we live in today is so backwards
sometimes but I actually think it shows
how desperate people people were a
to make sure that Hillary Clinton got
into office which still didn't work she
still is not our president thank God we
have Donald Trump there and you know the
fact that it keeps getting brought back
up and the media won't let it go they
keep bringing it back shows that they
have nothing else the president is doing
such a great job
they can't report on that because why
would I talk about it anymore which is
fascinating imagine if it was your
father-in-law though that he was the one
that paid for the Russian da see oh my
gosh imagine that it was your father
that was involved in giving 20% of
America's uranium to the bad actor Putin
and the hostile regime Russia we'd be in
a very different different yeah no we
would it's and it's a shame to see that
you know not a lot has been done to to
make sure that the right thing happens
here and I listen we see it time and
time again with the president the
there's so much against him and and
you're right had this happened and he
was behind it I could only imagine the
heads would be rolling he is so not the
typical politician it's interesting
after a year in the comments that I get
from people people I talk to every day
in social media what's interesting to me
is many people now they realize oh he's
not like every other president he's not
a politician and that means he's going
to say and tweet stuff that people are
quote I mean the media especially will
feign outrage over I think the America
is actually getting used to it in the
same oh that's refreshing yeah well it
is refreshing and keep in mind he's not
a politician he was a businessman who
was elected to be our president and look
at what he's done Sean in a year in
office his first year in office he
accomplished so much you see the economy
where it is right now see the Heritage
Foundation 64% of his agenda has already
done faster than Ronald ray it's
incredible it's incredible and yet no
one talks about it and again I still
maintain the reason that we hear about
Russia Russia Russia all the time is
because the the mainstream media has
nothing else they didn't get bear in the
umbrella all right I'm not giving my
kids the umbrella I'm keeping their
brother would have to report on all the
great things that he's done and they
won't do it so that's why you're here
I've got I know you Eric and and I know
Donna and I know your families and I met
you guys
more than anybody you seem to embrace
this this is not it this is a bloodsport
the world of politics
yeah how have you acclimated and taken
on this role that so many people would
never want to be a part of well listen I
grew up in North Carolina in a
middle-class family and I set it
throughout the campaign I would never
have gotten out there and put myself on
the line if I did not truly believe in
Donald Trump as a great leader and the
right man for the job and I'm so proud
to be a part of this family and the
support that I feel like we all give one
another it doesn't make it easy but it
makes it worth fighting for and and I'm
here to fight for this country because I
believe in what the president is doing
after eight horrific years of Obama we
need to change great to see you
congratulations on the baby and we hope
you'll come back soon and appreciate you
being with us